Hello Freak bitches.
Well,
also this outright thing that we were talking about,
there's a,
there's,
there's groups of people that were never interested in politics that are now
treating it the same way they treat sports.
The,
these guys are sports fans.
I mean,
that's really what it's like.
It's like,
this is my team.
I'm on team Trump,
you know,
and these fucking pussies.
Yeah,
it's a corporation man.
And they're showing up at these Berkeley rallies and they're fighting with
people now.
Like now you've,
you've got people responding.
This is one of the real problems with the left.
The real problem with these really hardcore lefties that are outraged and want
to do something and they want to be positive.
So they want to shut down all these people like Milo that the think or Nazis or
Ann Coulter and all these people.
But by doing that and by having these gigantic protest and literally shutting
down people,
communicating and talking,
you invite people to resist that.
And then you start eating these antifa people hit people on the head with
fucking bike locks.
You see the,
they found that it was a professor that was hitting people in the head with bike
locks and that this is going to have people show up and want to hit you with
something.
And so what you see now,
and I've seen plenty of footage of Trump protesters and supporters beating other
people out.
It's like ain't coming hold on both sides coming from both sides now.
But I almost feel like this is a manufactured thing because I think that there's
been from the Oakland area and I've an Antifa has been showing up at every
protest for as long as I can remember.
And the cops kind of like our hands off.
And so I feel like to provoke the Antifa block where you know that they're like
really strategically oriented and keep going to burglary and he'd going at
Berkeley and then making it like this big free speech blowout where it's like
why do you keep going?
And like creating the situation,
you kind of know what's going to happen.
It seems like a manufactured thing.
And then at the end of the day it makes the left easier to demonize.
And end basically protests easier to demonize,
where now you have 200 people facing felony riot charges at the inauguration
protests.
And a couple of them are just journalists who are filming and all the Trump
people are like,
whatever.
They're fucking writing.
And they're fascists in there.
Antifa it's like,
well,
because this happened in Berkeley now,
like all protesters are,
you know,
there's scapegoated to these people and to demonize.
It's easy to box people in,
but I think what's going on in Berkeley is it's the most outrageously liberal
place in the country.
Yeah.